first I want to connect the dots between
hole in the ground and this movie and I
guess maybe where we could start with
that is what would you say surprised you
most about the reality of what happens
when you have a successful first feature
and how that can open the door give you
opportunities connect you to other
people yeah I think it was a great
journey
um you know with the hole in the ground
premiering at Sundance in 2019 and
whilst I was there Sam Raimi had seen
the hole in the ground at a press
screening in La at the same time so
before I left Park City there had been
reaching out you know to actually meet
up and talk and then that meeting
started this journey that has us kind of
sitting in the room today but it is
great with your first feature like I
think with the hole in the ground it it
surprised a lot of people that came out
of Ireland but it had this particular
feel and tone that maybe people hadn't
seen and um and yeah there was lots of
wonderful conversations that were had
with different people but when Evil Dead
ran is poked it's kind of gnarly head up
over the parapet that was one that I was
going to find very hard to to not get
involved with so you knew that this was
on the table and a possibility back in
2019 2019. from our perspective I don't
think the news broke until like it might
have been like June 20th June 2020 I
think it was when yeah when when Bruce
had something to say but at that point
I'd just written the script because it
always takes a little bit of time and I
was busy so we kind of just talked about
it for a little while but for me from
July 2019 the guys had said like
absolutely go go go we want you to go
and do this and then I just started to
slowly develop and then write the script
in 2020. I can always count for the time
and you're like it's gone by so fast it
really has gone by so fast I have so
many questions the first is so when Sam
Raimi calls you up and asks you if you
have any interest in making an evil dead
movie if it like it feels like a
no-brainer you don't want to pass on an
opportunity like that but it's
intimidating to join one of the biggest
horror franchises out there so were
there any doubts especially because hole
in the ground is a very different
feeling kind of horror movie did you
know you always had it in you yeah I
always want I like when I remember
looking back my final short film I made
I think it came out like 10 years ago
at the same time as Evil Dead 2013 and I
remember just being that little bit
jealous at the time and I actually think
funny story that short ended up the
person doesn't work for ghost house
anymore but they saw the short and they
were like nah and they moved along and I
was like damn I really want to make an
evil dead movie someday
um and then I got that opportunity but I
didn't actually ever find it
overwhelming I was kind of excited but I
also knew what I wanted and what the
guys wanted was to do something that was
a little bit of departure a little bit
of a new Direction and and that actually
brought a certain Freedom it was kind of
liberating had I been telling a story in
the cabin in the woods with Ash I would
have been absolutely terrified but when
I kind of had the creative freedom to
tell a story that I was interested in
that again it just it just created a
certain I was at peace it was my
favorite script I've ever written my
favorite screenplay
it was so much fun to write like every
day was a joy whereas usually I'm just
Haggard and annoyed when I'm writing I
have scream on the brain right now
between that and this I very I feel very
spoiled in terms of getting new
installments of my favorite franchises
that have such like unique distinct feel
like they feel part of the franchise but
you also do something different I feel
like if you don't keep doing different
things then these franchises die yeah
very impressed yeah it's it's I think
it's it's just a really good time for
horror movies right now you know it's
always a good time for her it seems
particularly particularly nice right now
we've had a pretty good uh last two
years
um I want to go back to so many things
that just came to mind as you were
giving me that answer at first just
because you mentioned your shorts is
there any hope still for a ghost train
feature
absolutely absolutely yeah I know I've
got I have a very specific storyline
that I've had sitting there for a while
but just haven't had the opportunity
that is that is a movie that I would
absolutely to make a feature film you
know out of I think a lot of people when
they saw it felt like it was the opening
10 of something bigger
um but yeah there's there's a bigger
world and a bigger mythology there that
I'd really like to explore I will never
not be eager to see that movie so I will
be impatiently waiting when the time
comes for that one so you were talking a
little bit about crafting the script for
this was there anything that you would
call like your break story moment where
you came up with an idea and you're like
yes this is the way to make it evil dead
but also put my own unique stamp on it I
think it was a multitude of things I
think when I found the heart of the
characters and the family and within
that the metaphor that drives the story
I think that is always the moment for me
because that inspires the choices that
you then go on and make and even when
the Monstrous things happen and the
behavior and some of the dialogue with
with those dead eyes like it comes out
of that kind of deeper idea that deeper
you know fear of motherhood you know how
family can fall apart looking at some of
those theatrics or those thematic things
and also I when I I felt comfortable
with that I felt like then I could just
go and have a party with the horror at
that point so that was the turning point
in the writing once I knew the
characters then it was like let's get
the tools out and have some fun one of
my absolute favorite things about your
movie that I think makes it feel
different from all the other Evil Dead
movies is that you have the grounded
truly scary horror beats but you also
have that that quintessential evil dead
humor that encourages people to like
share a communal like laugh of relief so
is there any particular non-spoiler
moment where you can kind of talk us
through finding that right balance there
I I think the I think the already
Infamous Daphne moment is probably a
good one to look at because what happens
is so outlandish and I think where the
audience get the fun out of that moment
is they were in on the trick at the
beginning they were aware of the
development of this thing they saw this
let's call it weapon getting made and
then when it returns it comes out of
nowhere but it's also planted through
character in just a couple of scenes
before where there's a call back to how
this this thing might offer protection
and then it does offer protection in a
very very brutal way Stephanie is just
absolute genius was that always in the
script from day one yeah it was it was
in my head before I even wrote Evil Dead
rise my little niece Georgia who lives
in Ireland my sister's kid loves horror
movies she's like me when I was her age
in terms of the family she loves her
she's like well now she's 14 but she was
probably about nine and I called into my
sisters one day she loved that I'm
telling this story and she was like hey
I've got to show you something and I'm
like what and she's like meet Stephanie
so I was like Beth in that moment except
it never ended up with a pointed end but
she has the OG Stephanie at home which
is going to bring to the premiere in
Dublin so she was the creator of
Stephanie and I have to give her props
for that what I then did with it was
turn it into something incredibly
violent
like my type of really wholesome family
story
so one of my favorite things about Evil
Dead overall is that it's
like in order to make an evil dead movie
or a show you don't play by any rules
you just go for it but of course it's in
it's important to you know keep together
the mythology to an extent so of all the
rules that govern the Evil Dead
franchise which one was most important
for you to uphold but then also is there
anything about the Necronomicon and
deadite mythology that you were eager to
like either shake up or add as a new
layer to the franchise I think yeah I
think the thing it's lesser rule but the
thing that I wanted to hold up was the
Relentless entertaining Terror basically
that combination
so when I was working on the screenplay
I had a post note that was just like
make it entertaining and what I knew at
entertaining meant I meant like you know
like a Thrill Ride a blood train call it
what you want that was really important
because I looked Evil Dead too as so
entertaining like a cross in fact Evil
Dead 2 just starts you know what I mean
there's not a lot of build but I always
liked that relentlessness so that
Relentless horror entertainment was
really important I knew I wanted the
book I knew I wanted the shotgun I knew
I had to have the chainsaw those things
needed to be there
um and I think then from my point of
view it's actually one of the fun things
about taking on the Evil Dead is that
you don't necessarily need to have uh
perfect rules because there's a certain
kind of nightmare logic at play in that
world so maybe in another horror movie
you'd have to explain how an elevator
can fill with blood
um in an evil dead movie you don't need
to explain that because the force itself
that's released is so Insidious in
nature it's infecting I remember
thinking at one point how much I could
infect the building the actual fabric of
the building itself and had a lot of
thoughts about kind of crazy stuff I
could do but it got in the way of
telling the story at that point but I
kept little bits of it with the way the
elevator particularly behaves as a kind
of character in its own right in the
story need to swing big in that respect
otherwise what is the point in making
another Evil Dead movie exactly exactly
I love that so you gotta you gotta push
it out so you were just talking about
like pushing it and going big and
creating this like non-stop wild ride
but another thing you do in this movie
that really impresses me is like you
seem to know exactly when to pull back
and take a moment to to build dread and
earn those big moments so are there any
particular again non-spoiler for now
moments where you know you you purposely
slowed things down and gave something a
beat before going back to like the big
Crazy dead-eyed Action yeah I think when
the true reality of what has taken place
is presented to the characters there's a
moment you know where the movie turns
and it it goes and it goes again and it
goes again and then it goes really hard
and then there's like an argument
between the siblings in the story
although it's not a brat because they're
under pressure but it is a moment where
they slightly get to take stock of the
new reality that they're facing and I
thought beats like that are very very
important or also there's a very
important beat between Beth and Cassie
later on rakassi asks asks her auntie is
this a nightmare and also tells her that
she'll be a good mom someday those
little moments are really important to
breathe and to get inside the psychology
of these characters because without the
psychology without you know them
breathing real and you being inside them
in some way and then horror is just
spectacle and nothing else right you
need to love these people all I could
think about is poor Cassie I know my God
you put that poor child through so much
yeah there's some therapy build ahead my
heart I'll add one more non-spoiler
question before we shift gears here what
was your initial reaction when you first
heard that initially at least the movie
was going to premiere on HBO Max and not
in theaters you know I was a little bit
disappointed at that point in time
because I was riding the screenplay as a
theatrical experience
um but I also understood where we were
in the world at the time and I respect
why those decisions have to be made and
with certain projects in relation to you
know home viewing and making sure that
you know the people and for me at that
point I was like as long as people can
get eyeballs on this story I'll be happy
but I never lost sight that I thought it
could be a theatrical Endeavor and I
believed with covert and all of that
stuff that if the people would go back
to the cinema and if people went back to
the cinema they're going to want to
watch something fun maybe less
existential and just more entertaining
so in my I always had hope in my heart
that those things would line up and
thankfully they did they did with like
the right support from from new line and
and and the people at Warner's they gave
me the opportunity to to test that movie
and to uh to see how an audience
response would respond and then they
realized this is this is an audience
participation dark room big screen
spectacle